so up next we are going to hear from mr
mark allen so it is my pleasure to
welcome mr mark allen he is a google
cloud account manager for the national
institute of health he is focused on
extramural researcher as net enablement
prior to joining google marked work at
microsoft aiding his higher education
clients to adopt the cloud
mark has a bs in business administration
from the california university of
pennsylvania and msit from carnegie
mellon university so please join me in
welcoming mr mark allen
oh can we
mark a co-host please
hey can you guys hear me okay
yes we can
excellent thank you very much
um thanks for the intro laura i really
appreciate it i also invited ashoke who
is a business development rep here at
google cloud
and she's going to share off the slides
i'm working from my phone and my ipad
today unfortunately so
uh if you wouldn't mind sharing all
those slides please
sorry who's uh ashoki is it akshay
uh ogus
i o k e
and then our last name is vfo there you
go perfect
excellent all right i think we're good
thank you much thank you very much
ashoke um so as mentioned i'm i'm mark
allen uh i worked at microsoft for nine
years before joining google
uh and again and very much helping my uh
higher education customers adopt the
cloud i'm based out of san francisco
california but i did work for microsoft
uh two years in the east coast outside
of new york city
uh prior to joining microsoft i was in
the customer space i was actually in
education i was a director of it
and and you know worked on a lot of
infrastructure stuff i won't get all the
details of course so i kind of still
maintain that customer perspective
really
uh next slide please
uh so here's our quick agenda we're
going to talk a little bit briefly about
why google cloud i'm going to try my
best not to mention any any product
names i think i'm going to mention one
and then we're going to talk about nih
and the strides program of course why
you're here uh how to join the program
and then what happens after you enroll
right and then we'll switch to a q a and
uh and we'll go from there
so first off why google cloud so next
next slide please subscribe so when you
think of google you probably think of
the search engine right the very generic
white background uh beautifully colored
letters
uh and you type in your search and
within milliseconds you get your results
right uh the next slide but what you
don't think of
is the infrastructure behind it right
there are thousands of servers
that are running the google.com search
engine as well as all of our
applications uh matter of fact we've
been google has been building you know
consumer based applications since 97
right
so if you go to the next slide you'll
see kind of a great timeline and a
history of the the major products that
google has released we've been in the
consumer space since before 97
and each of these applications on here
has a billion users for each application
two of them actually have two billion
users and you'll note that all of them
are 100
powered by machine learning right so
you're gonna have access to slide deck
and if you look at the little blue uh
notes beneath each application there is
at least two of the the machine learning
powered uh features of those
applications right i guarantee if you
have children they're using youtube i
know my nieces religiously
and so you know we've definitely helped
with machine learning to do some better
thumbnails better recommendations right
always always looking at the algorithm
and making sure that our consumers are
kind of getting the
the needs that they have
uh next slide please
a few more little tidbits about google
right so google is the world's largest
purchaser of renewable energy in fact
all of our global operations have been
powered by 100 renewable energy since
2017.
uh here you got a couple pictures of the
the big windmills of course the
the wind farm and then the solar panel
as well right so
we're very committed to sustainability
and going green and so if you partner
with google you are definitely making a
green choice as well next slide
one of the reasons i joined google is
their dedication to hybrid and
multi-cloud solutions
other cloud providers certainly have
this i'm not here to knock on them but
essentially you know their their
approach is more of a hardware
uh lock-in or a vendor login right uh
google's approach uh even outside of
hybrid multi-cloud is is a
software-based approach right um so we
have developed you know google
kubernetes and now that is certainly a
defective standard out in the world
right
um
what the only problem i'll mention is
anthis right anthos is built on that
kubernetes engine and and this is kind
of a big game changer it's a
software-based solution that allows you
to essentially run google cloud services
on-premises or in other clouds even
right
so we have a lot of great flagship
products and maybe you say hey my data
is is on-premise and i need to keep it
on premise
you can bring the cloud down to you with
with anthos right um so we're very
committed to hybrid and multi-cloud
solutions and the approach
if you know uh
ideally one day everybody's in the cloud
uh you know but along the way we're
gonna have you know certainly a hybrid
approach as well as many cloud providers
involved
next slide
a couple slides real quick on security
our approach to security in two words is
trust nothing
and if you go to the next slide
essentially what i'm talking about here
is we don't consider
traffic any internet traffic um whether
it's internal or external to be
different right there's no difference as
far as we're concerned so we build in
uh layered defense in depth right
because we essentially look for
mitigations and multiple defenses within
each layer and in between each layer
right
and so with this approach we've
essentially been able to create a very
secure cloud computing area next slide
if you have any compliance needs we
certainly meet all or exceed all the
government requirements for security and
privacy protection uh we're happy to
give you some security attestation
reports uh you can just go to our cloud
security command center and and take a
look at all the reports yourself as well
but we have all the big ones of course
fedramp we have the high trust we have
hipaa
uh there's a bunch of iso ones as well
so whatever your needs are chances are
we meet those needs and if we don't
we're certainly working willing to work
with you on getting those compliance
certifications
all right next slide and then slide that
so what a stride so take a brief second
to talk about the national institutes of
health so nih is comprised of 27
institutes centers and offices uh we
just call them ics so apologies if i use
acronyms but when i say i see i just
mean one of the ics uh regarding the nih
i got a couple examples up there uh the
presentation before me i think mentioned
nci as well so i think you're familiar
with that one
i put a link for the reporter up here
the reporter is an nih tool that they
have built that allows anybody to kind
of see all of the grants that are out
there per institution or even per pi
principal investigator right so
you're welcome to use that reporter and
kind of see you know you can see how
much funding your institutions you know
received what grants your pis are
working on
all the good stuff there essentially
what i didn't uh what i didn't actually
put on the slide is
regarding
how nih's funding is set up and it's
very very complex but at a very high
level
uh if you read their strategic report
eighty percent of their funding goes to
external universities uh sorry
extramural institutions um out of that
eighty percent seventy percent uh is
roughly uh all higher education right um
so that's around 50
of their total budget their total budget
for 2022 was around 49 billion dollars
uh so nih is committed to extramural
research and allowing others to
kind of you know do the research that
makes sense from a biomedical standpoint
uh next slide okay so we're keeping on
this slide actually uh
so strides right let's talk about
strides uh strides is an acronym of
course it stands for the science of
technology research infrastructure for
discovery experimentation and
sustainability
essentially it's a program they built
because they see the value in cloud
and they're really just trying to
accelerate biomedical discovery right
google was first to enter this
partnership in july of 2018
aws signed on recently after that as
well and then i think microsoft azure
just signed up in july of 2021 right so
all the three major cloud providers are
in there um you know but we're a little
unique in that not only do they partner
with us first but our ai and ml
capabilities as i kind of mentioned
before
are are differentiated enough that that
we have a very big uh say in kind of how
that ai is done right i won't talk about
alpha fold here but that's certainly one
of the the hot buzzwords when it comes
to machine learning right um and and
that's kind of true to just google's
testament of ai machine learning
next slide please
from a benefit standpoint when you sign
on to the strides program the the first
benefit most people realize right away
is those deep discounts on google cloud
now normally i put the pricing table in
here uh because we're being reported
i've elected not to do that but i can
verbally say at least that the there is
25 discount on compute and storage the
25 discount on compute applies to all
compute resources including gpus
so if you have high compute needs the
discounts are there and and they're
provided to you you know via google
cloud from nih again to get more
research for your dollar right and
hopefully hopefully to
ex
uh accelerate that biomedical discovery
uh other big disc other big benefits we
always talk about are the access to
training there's a discount on training
programs as well we also have for some
free no cost training options i'll talk
about this briefly at the end
you'll also get a direct relationship
with nih right we're happy to kind of
make connections to program officers
people within ics uh whoever it makes
sense to kind of have a conversation to
talk more about the research the
programs and and then if you're
enrolling in strides and you actually
have some
uh you know architecture discussion
questions we can certainly make those
connections as well
and of course that last big benefit is
that faster time to insights again we're
always trying to get
the results quicker so you can spend
more time on on the science versus on
the infrastructure itself
uh one next slide and then so one big
thing i want to point out is there is no
upfront commitment to joining strides
there's no money you pay to get into the
program essentially that is provided at
no cost because you're going to use nih
dollars for your research in the cloud
and then next slide
so another
great
benefit is increased advocacy right so
everybody on this call has an account
team at google cloud right every
university every college you have an
account team at google cloud that
account team usually uh consists of an
account manager like myself you probably
have a customer engineer which kind of
the more technical
person on that call or engage with you
and there's probably a few others that
are on your account team on the energy
account team as well right i'm one of
the account managers we have support we
have consulting we have customer
engineers and architects data scientists
it's a really large account team
and if you if you click on the slide
real quick show key so when you join the
program you essentially get you know the
advocacy from both your account team as
well as us right so we're here to help
any nih-funded researcher
get what they need to out of google
cloud essentially right obviously within
reason but my role as account manager is
to be an advocate for
nih as an account but also anybody i'm
working with right i'm focused on
extramurals so it's around 3000
institutions i'm working with
uh next slide
up and then there's a quick little red
blurb via more advocacy than google and
with nih as well right
next slide
public data set so one of the big
another big feature of the strides
program itself is trying to get access
to you know open data right trying to
make sure that the data that biomedical
researchers need is available in the
cloud i think on the presentation before
this i heard anvil sorry um all of us uh
and so all of us is actually working
with uh the team there and we're getting
all of us on google cloud as well right
so there's a lot of great uh public data
sets we have available we have some that
are
uh publicly available but not in the in
the program itself but you can still
access them there's things like imaging
data commons there's sra toolkits uh
we're always adding more data sets as
well right so i'm currently working with
a pi out of ucsf who manages a 400
terabyte database and we're working with
uh the program manager for the public
data assist program to get it in the
cloud right um with the way we see it
the more data that's in the cloud the
quicker your research can get done you
don't have to spend time moving your
data around massaging it it's already
there it's already ready to go and you
can just kind of start your research
next slide
all right flexible options to join let's
dive into this right so
i showed you i'm going to have you uh
click when i say click if you don't mind
this this slide builds out right so if
you don't mind click click once
and so this is you you are a researcher
out there uh and and you know maybe
you're getting nih funded dollars maybe
you're getting funds from other
organizations you know whatever it may
be
click again
and so you are probably reporting up to
a department uh if you click again
that department has other researchers
and click again
and then again that department's up into
a school or institute and if you click
it one more time you know that reports
up to a university
that might have more schools it might
have an academic med center right but
essentially there are nih funded
researchers all throughout this
organization and so what our goal is to
sign the strides agreement at the
highest level right we're happy to sign
individual researchers uh departments
schools institutes whatever it takes
right because sometimes that university
procurement process can take you know
five eight nine months right so when you
have nih funded dollars and you want to
kind of experience the benefits
especially the discounts right away
we're happy to work with you to get you
signed in as quickly as possible right
if you click one more time
the one thing that we really really like
to have too is kind of an i.t support as
well right so
we understand not every organization has
it support or maybe research computing
and so it doesn't need to be a
full-fledged i.t we just need somebody
that is kind of going to be that point
person for billing ids
and and really understanding the process
right so we work with that person or
team of people to make sure they
understand the process what information
is needed to get an id a billing id and
then and then kind of you know giving
out from there right
um so this is kind of like like the the
pyramid that we go to the pyramid of
what we're trying to get to right the
higher we sign the more benefits all the
nih researchers
next slide
so i'm going to talk about these options
to sign on very very quickly because
they can get into weeds very very
quickly as well so we have three major
options first option is direct to care
soft uh carosoft is the federal
distributor of the google cloud service
for nih right and for many of our actual
public sector customers uh if you click
once this is a very very simple process
you would essentially engage with
carousel we would set up those
conversations and you can essentially
sign on very very easily
if you go to the next slide this is
where we have a little more flexibility
and this is where most of our education
customers kind of want to fall right
and so you'll notice i have the same
image kind of twice and so we'll talk
about it uh twice essentially so we have
two we have a few results to work with
the two that most of our customers sign
through it's onyx and burbot group
both of these resellers are a value-add
reseller and they they first there's no
further uh
margin right it's not like they're
cutting into the discounts at all
you sign on with them and it's still no
cost but both of them actually have a
very unique billing tool
and if you are that kind of i.t person
that is going to be doing all the
billing ids
that
those building tools that they provide
are are just hugely helpful as far as
being able to kind of differentiate
where the money is going per grant and
for project right
so if you are interested in joining
strides we will definitely loop in onyx
and burwood you can have a conversation
with them if you like not to go with a
reseller and just stick direct to
carousel through option one the billing
is going to be kind of up to you right
making sure that you are able to report
on the billing is going to be full in
your hands um and and the reason for
that for all of this essentially is
all these funds are federal funds right
which means they're they're subject to
congressional reporting uh and nih is
very big on this of course uh and we all
should be too it's our tax dollars so um
but essentially if if it's not reported
well then there's definitely a lot of
questions right so uh engaging with onyx
and broadway your best best way to go
they have a very great tool
on the right they'll notice the only
difference is internet2
right
you are welcome to sign on with
internet2 you can be a member or a
non-member but if you if you sign the
strides agreement through 2 you also get
to realize not only the benefits of the
strides program but the benefits of
internet 2 as well and so i'll cover
those in about two more slides
if you click once there's another little
red blurb no increase in price with the
use of a reseller right
next slide please
now the last one's very very quick and
dirty essentially if you already have an
existing agreement with google cloud or
with carasoft we can leverage that
agreement as well right there's not many
customers that fall into this category
uh it's typically let's let's use a
reseller let's use you know make sure we
also get internet too um this is
something you're also welcome to explore
if you want to
next slide please
uh this is just a quick summary i'm not
going to cover this in the interest of
time but you are welcome to read it uh
and you know ask any questions later if
you need to
next slide please
so internet two so
there's an internet to net plus gcp
agreement right this was pre-negotiated
with four universities
uh to kind of provide benefits to
members and non-members quite frankly um
uh for internet too and for google cloud
essentially uh so
essentially there's um
the biggest thing we always talk about
is if
you join through internet 2 not only
will your nih workloads get to 25
discount but any non nih workload will
receive a 5 discount on compute and
storage as well right there's also a lot
of other benefits of course uh we invite
you to reach out to that email address
netplus at internet2 you work with a guy
named bob flynn uh bob is from indiana
university one of the initial four
universities that helped uh
negotiate this contract and bob's
amazing so i can't talk about him enough
he's very knowledgeable uh he's very
customer focused uh and then he'll tell
such a straight so i invite you to reach
out to that email email address and talk
to bob
and uh and he'll tell you all the cool
stuff
next slide please
all right here's just a quick list of uh
internet 2 net plus google cloud
subscribers right your college or
university may be signed on to netplus
but maybe through azure maybe 3ws uh
maybe you're a non-member of internet
too as well right so this is a quick
list and i put the link in the in the
notes you're welcome to kind of bridge
that as well
next slide
all right so after enrolling in strides
uh we we engaged with internet2 and we
got some feedback right that we asked a
lot of questions you know to ask a lot
of questions i should say on kind of hey
you have access to the strides program
you're an nih researcher
you know why is there a disconnect why
are you not using the strides program
right
and the biggest result we got back was
actually just communication they just
weren't aware they had access to it and
so we have kind of created a success
plan to make sure that going forward
when a university or college or med
center or even just department signs on
this is kind of a the key to success to
make sure that all the researchers there
know they have access to it and how to
get access to it so to start again we
have an it support process it's more
about the billing account id process it
doesn't need to be it can be recomputing
it can be a pi or pi's assistant we have
a few of those examples um just somebody
that's kind of there to say yep i know i
need to get this type of information
from a researcher
and then i can i can send it to nih and
i will get my
my project id my billing id right so a
very very simple process we just kind of
need that one person at least
the other major things we found is
having a website i think on this page it
says a public page it doesn't need to be
public we do have two examples from nyu
and university of wisconsin-madison
welcome to read those
but it could be on your internet as well
but some type of web page that for
researchers that kind of says here's the
nih strides program here's why it's
important to you and here's how to get
access to it right
after that website's completely
finalized uh an email needs to be kind
of sent some type of communication
whatever that may be uh sent out to the
research community at that university
saying hey you have access to this check
out the webpage you have any questions
here's some email addresses or people to
reach out to whatever it might be and
then finally a launch event um this used
to just say webinar i've added seminar
because things are opening up now and
then hopefully we can get on-site to
customers more but essentially having uh
you know a large audience of people that
are that are
interested in nih funded research and
and interesting google cloud you know
join the webinar seminar kind of saying
hey here's all the questions i'll answer
your questions here's the program works
uh google's happy to join those and i
just happen to join those the resellers
internet too they're all happy to join
we're here for you guys so
um after you guys sign up and we want to
get to that point of like hey let's make
sure we evangelize the strides program
we're here to help make that happen
next slide please
another piece of feedback from that
internet2 survey was around training now
i'm going to talk briefly at the end
about some free and no cost training
options i also wanted to highlight that
we work with nih very very closely and
we last year we helped develop custom
training right the title is introduction
to biomedical data science in google
cloud we delivered it seven times in
2021 to the intramural researchers
i think the first three times there's
you know kind of reiterations of let's
make sure we we change this or modify
this or speak about this more this this
thing less
but after those three initial
trainings the last four went off without
a hitch we had a lot of success and
we do always seek anonymous feedback and
so there's a quote there from a
researcher who joined one of those
sessions
there's 16 attendees per class there's a
sample agenda on the right
if you're interested in training
whether it's just custom training or
other training options feel free to
reach out and we'll put you in touch
with your account manager to talk
through those
next slide
okay i am almost finished here so
this is an eyesore i apologize and this
is two
screenshots from a doc i have and so
you're gonna get access to the pdf with
all these links at a very very high
level i'm going to talk about just a few
of them right the top left is the google
cloud free trial
so everybody is welcome to get 300 in
credits of google cloud services uh it
does require a credit card but i will
point out that it will not charge your
credit card uh until you say so right
and until that's that 300 expired so
what happens is you put your credit card
in your 300 credits there's also a free
tier available where we have certain
cloud services that are always free
you're welcome to use those credits
until they're exhausted after they're
exhausted then you're prompted do you
want to use your credit card or not you
can say no
and that's it you won't get charged
it'll shut down your services and we can
all move on right so
i know there's always hesitation using
credit card but but google is very open
on this and very aware of of the fears
so
please don't be hesitant to to sign into
that program
i'm gonna jump down to
uh google cloud research credits
if you have a research project that you
are working on uh and you know maybe you
applied for nih grant and you didn't get
it
but it's a cool research topic you're
welcome to click on that link and apply
for reached credits from google i think
we do up to five thousand dollars
and so we'll help fund your project in
the cloud
uh the next two links are about learning
google cloud right there's a lot of free
online labs quests courses a lot of
great stuff in there about about free
training essentially invite you to check
those out as well
the link below that is google cloud for
researchers so if you are a researcher
you're also welcome to get some credits
and some free training with that
below that is google cloud for students
uh again if you are a student you wanna
you're trying to learn some more about
google cloud you're welcome to apply to
that program as well
uh the top right though is if you are a
faculty and you're saying hey i'm
actually gonna teach a class on
uh you know biomedical research and
we're going to use google cloud that's
the program you would use where you
would get the credits then dish out to
your students right
so we're very big on free education
programs and providing credits to
students and faculty as well as
researchers
there's a few more links in there i
think one of the ones i would definitely
want to highlight is
the public sector cloud community it's
the third from the last we call it
pubset connect it's run by a woman named
kate johnson and it's
you know there's there's no sales
discussions allowed right it's it's it's
individual to individual and so
essentially other customers talking to
other customers about their experience
in the cloud their challenges their
successes
it's a great community there's a call i
think every week
and a lot of great presenters on there
as well
um google cloud communities below that
is basically you can kind of engage with
product managers here at google on your
questions and then i put a certification
link there below as well
if you click once for miyashoki
a nice big red box should appear so
uh as much as i try to highlight some of
these uh discussion points uh there's a
session by alice cayman to help put
mostly programs together that was
delivered yesterday so i invite you to
check that out on the youtube
she goes into in depth into most of
these programs uh and again if you have
questions for her to reach out
uh next slide
so the next slide is uh i think just a
quick call to action the call to action
is very simple it is basically if you
have any questions if you're interested
in learning about strides google cloud
google workspace you have any questions
at all feel free to reach out uh and if
you go to the next slide we have some
email addresses up here for you right so
the top is me i am mark c allen uh i had
to use my middle initial there
i showed keystone call as well like i
mentioned she's a business development
rep uh if if you have kind of lights or
high level questions uh she would
probably be best to email she'd probably
get back to much quicker than i can but
you're welcome to email me as well right
please don't think uh i don't want your
emails i do
the last email there is the google cloud
strides team and so this is the entire
account team for nih it includes people
from support consulting we have
architects and data scientists on this
email so if you kind of have a broader
question feel free to email that alias
and uh and we'll be happy to answer your
questions for you uh if you have any
doubts feel free to just email me and i
will reach the right people and we'll
get you squared away
and the next slide is just q a so i will
open the floor
for any q a
thank you mark for that very informative
talk so in the interest of time we are
actually going to have any questions
that you have for mark to please forward
to us and we can pass those along to you
later is that all right mark perfect
thank you very much sorry if i went over
i apologize and uh